for many people throughout the pandemic
dinner plans
usually look like this you look up your
favorite local restaurant on an app like
ubereats
or deliveroo if you're in the uk place
an order
track it on the map grab the bag from
your doorstep and voila
dinner delivered but sometimes in those
bags
restaurants include notes like these
encouraging customers to order directly
from them next time
that would mean they don't have to pay
delivery companies commission fees of
up to 35 percent restaurants around the
world have organized to push delivery
services to lower their fees
while recognizing these apps have become
very important
they are massively crucial um
begrudgingly
crucial actually it's it's hard giving
away
your hard-earned cash to a platform but
yeah they're keeping us afloat
while restaurants have been struggling
amid the pandemic delivery services like
uber and doordash have boomed
by the end of 2020 food delivery
spending had more than doubled compared
to 2019
but spending at restaurants was down
roughly 5
that will be the legacy of the pandemic
in this sector everyone had to change
their behavior overnight so
are delivery apps helping restaurants or
hurting them
the food delivery market as we know it
actually started about 20 years ago when
grubhub in the u.s
and just eat in europe entered the
market the generation one operators
the roots of this business model were
working with independent restaurants
and independent restaurants that had
existed for decades prior to the
platform coming along i got my delivery
bag and my bike
and i'm going to spend a couple of hours
doing some orders
giles thorne researches european
internet companies for jefferies
and to better understand the food
delivery industry he spent some time
actually making deliveries for deliveroo
in the uk in 2019 and 2020.
everything changed in around 2016 2017
because a generation two competition
came in
and these were delivery-led these were
platforms like deliveroo
like doordash like ubereats that saw
that uh the consumer valued the utility
of an online food delivery
and that the branded chains the big
restaurants not the
independent pizza parlor in london but
the mcdonald's three doors along
would also benefit from the utility of
this type of platform
there are a lot of companies vying to
take control of the food delivery
industry right now
the global market was projected to be
worth 285 billion dollars in 2020.
margins are low meaning despite high
demand delivery companies mostly operate
at a loss
the reason why a platform will not be
making money at this point in time
is essentially because they are in a
competitive market
they are having to spend a large amount
of money primarily through marketing
to get consumers to download the app and
start using them the platform says
right i got three other guys in my
market by the end of next year
i want to get two of them to exit so i'm
gonna spend 100 million dollars
buying up every billboard and i'm going
to send a message to the other guys that
they are not going to get traffic
and that's the logic that's why people
don't make money
since the delivery market's inception
there has been a lot of consolidation
just eat has undergone six major mergers
and acquisitions in the last five years
last year it was acquired by
takeaway.com which then acquired grubhub
for 7.3 billion dollars
in the u.s ubereats acquired post mates
for 2.65 billion in stock
in december 2020 doordash went public
by the end of the year the company was
worth at least 50 billion dollars
uber doordash and grubhub now control
roughly 98
of the overall u.s food delivery market
in terms of transactions
in the united kingdom uber eats just eat
and deliveroo
are among the most popular food delivery
apps
one restaurant working with delivery
services like these is
thai kitchen in london we set up the
business
just before covert hit we literally were
open a week before the pandemic
the owner richard poole has relied on
services like ubereats and deliveroo
to keep the restaurant alive during
various levels of lockdown since march
2020.
loads of plants were in the in the
pipeline when it came to us having you
know eating
eating service and having that extra
revenue stream but obviously
that went to pot so we had to um let's
improvise
thai kitchen also offers its own service
for in-store collection
we'd hardly have our own delivery
service but obviously it's a lot the
logistical nightmare of having your own
delivery service is is really it's real
it's
it's a real challenge that's why we
outsource it to deliver new breeds to
to deliver our food um another thing is
uh delivery new breeds have
uh they can they basically own all the
drivers
it's very very hard to find um
independent well
they technically they are independent
right but it's very hard to find someone
who'd come over to work with you
you know i mean because they basically
they they own the fleets
uber eats has nearly 5 million drivers
and delivery people globally
and doordash has over 1 million most
apps offer restaurants a range of
services
from just helping facilitate online
ordering to actually delivering the food
if the app handles the delivery the fees
can range from
10 to 35 of the total order the whole
balance of deliveries and takeaways
right now it's it's like 80 percent
deliveries right but all 85 from from
our point of view
so i think let's say to improve things
would be more people actually coming to
collect because if you come collect an
order
you basically give the restaurant 100 of
the revenue
these tensions over commission fees
aren't new mcdonald's franchisees have
complained publicly that uber eats
erodes their margins
while uber has said it offers some large
restaurant chains a lower service fee
in 2019 representatives from the two
companies said they reached a new deal
and since the pandemic hit various
regions in the u.s
including new york la and philadelphia
have temporarily capped delivery fees
for restaurants at 10 to 15 percent
doordash has said the commission caps
ultimately restrict restaurant choice
precisely when restaurants need the full
range of options to help their
businesses survive and
thrive some restaurants are even working
out of ghost kitchens where they cook
food
exclusively for delivery services uber
eats drivers have switched off their
hailing apps this weekend to demand
better treatment
from the food delivery service delivery
apps have also come under pressure from
gig
workers demanding better employment
protections including
better wages and sick pay the ceo of
uber recently called for dialogue
but said its delivery app allows workers
to make money in a flexible way
doordash grubhub and ubereats told the
wall street journal they've provided
drivers with various ppe
and just eat said it supports contact
free delivery and has given restaurants
reduced commission fees throughout the
pandemic
as these companies have become a key
part of many people's lives
regulators are watching to see the
impact on competition
consumers delivery drivers and
restaurants
it's very hard to see our money go like
that amount go to um
to them but again they are they uh
credit wage two they are keeping us
afloat so even with the commission rates
being that high if it wasn't for them
we'd actually have to shut